foreign
[Music]
this is the fast time to value with
bigquery migration Services session
which means we're going to be talking
about migrations to bigquery and what we
have been doing over the last one year
on the technology front on our Global
Consulting front
as well as on our partner front
if you're a customer welcome welcome if
you're a partner even more special
welcome
all right let's get started
so I'm Mohit I am the product manager
who is responsible for migrations to
Google's data analytics portfolio and
with me we have a very special speaker a
very special guest today GB varghese
from Seattle Children's Hospital
this is a very special customer on
multiple fronts first they've recently
migrated to bigquery so they can share
their experience
the second is they're from a highly
regulated industry so you know if there
are nuances if there are challenges in
migration please throw all of that at GB
and me during the Q a all right let's
get started
today uh We've laid it out in four
sections and the first piece is for
those of you who are joining us after a
while we'll do a quick catch up
of who we are and what we've been doing
the second part is going to be
some really cool announcements of what's
available starting now and what's going
to be available in about five to six
weeks from now so some enhancements and
some really cool announcements there
then I'll hand it over to GB he's going
to walk you through Seattle Children's
Journey
uh both on their technical stack as well
as from their migration perspective
and then we'll uh have a question
answered towards the end
all right just to recap I'm sure you've
been hearing this over and over again
but just to recap
bigquery is the core of Google's data
analytics engine
uh there are three things
Limitless data so literally by virtue of
the almost infinite scalability
there is Limitless data but there are
also Limitless possibilities of what you
can do with your data
there is Limitless reach so
if you have your data infrastructure and
bigquery your data can do a lot of
things for you that's not the uh the
topic for today's talk but just want to
do you know refresh that and finally
Limitless workloads so announcements
that are happening today work that the
team has been doing over the past year
and before that enables your workloads
literally to scale infinitely
let's jump into the bigquery migration
services
and just for folks at the back my timer
isn't working so I'm still showing the
entire 45 minutes
so if you go over stair fault not mine
all right
bigquery migration service quick recap
four components
as we literally historically have talked
about it
one is assessment so if you're a
customer or if you're a partner who's
helping a customer migrate
how do you analyze
three things one what is the current
state of your workload on your Source
system so if you're on terror data if
you're in a teaser or if you're an
oracle how do you analyze what are the
complexities what are the
interrelationships of your workload the
second thing all this is within
assessment the second thing is
what would your landed State on bigquery
look like
and the third thing is how do you get
there
so assessment as an automated service
covers all of that
the next piece the power horse the
Workhorse of bigquery migration service
is the automated SQL translation
this is the industry best and
probably one of the most performant
automated SQL translations available
from 14 plus sources to bigquery
we complement that with a data transfer
service for a few sources and then there
is automated data validation now I'm not
claiming that these services are
automated 100 but a constant effort is
to get these to as close to 100 as
possible and then help you the partner
or you the customer be able to cover the
manual steps in a more deterministic
fashion
tutorially if you just take the Yellow
Boxes represent roughly what a migration
looks like different steps in a
migration
what we do is we try to make Solutions
available parts of the service available
corresponding to each of those either by
ourselves which is the blue boxes
or with our partners and our
Professional Services
which is the gray boxes
what we're trying to do is if you were
here with us last year this picture was
much sparse what we've been trying to do
is add either our components or with the
help of our partners you know solutions
from them so that when we go to you
meaning our sales team goes to you as a
customer or the partners team goes to
you for a migration plan a statement of
work we try to cover as much of this as
possible with two things
one all of this is free so we're
enabling the customer and the partner
to drive down the cost of migrations
instead if you are a partner helping the
customer you can focus on optimizing the
customer stack once they're in bigquery
so that's a little bit of a paradigm
shift
the second thing is our aim is to make
each of these steps less about onion
peeling and more deterministic so it's
the determinism in each of these steps
that we've been working to add
consistently so be it increasing the
depth in our assessment automated
assessment which can now be run within
like a couple of days
to uh less than a week for you to be
able to see a full automated report
or be it SQL translation we've been
continuously improving the capabilities
of automation
so just a quick recap
where are we today
the items in red are recent enhancements
but again the four uh bullets here
corresponding correspond to the four
components that we saw so in assessment
we
are recently added teradata in general
availability with total cost of
ownership and redshift so these are both
pretty performant now
we also have brought batch and
interactive translations and what are
those batch is when you point your
workload and the entire workload gets
automatically translated interactive is
Google translate like left to right you
can go query by query so what we've done
is we've brought batch and interactive
translations at parity your interactive
translation now has the same context as
your batch so if you fed in metadata if
you fed in rules now if you use
interactive translation it's going to
have the same output with the same
Source context
and we've added recently added
sources including btec for teradata hql
IBM netiza these were recently turned
into generally available they were in
preview before and then we've added
Presto and vertica in preview
uh data migration gravity we are working
with partners and more on this coming
soon but we have first party tooling for
teradata and redshift and through our
partners we have partner tooling for
some of the other sources
data validation one of the good things
that's been recently added in addition
to the sources
is the ability to dry it on which means
that now if you use the data validation
piece you can ask it to just print out
source and destination SQL queries
without actually doing the validation
pretty powerful construct think about it
for a minute
some numbers just to show the scale
we've been supporting
these include customers from
across the verticals so if you're a
Healthcare Customer you're represented
here if you're a retail customer you're
also represented here
the two parts to this one is the
assessment where we're showing how our
automated assessment is able to cover
large scale inquiries as well as large
volume of data and these are real
customer numbers
on the code translation piece look at
the automation rates
you'll hear numbers being thrown on the
industry these are actual outcomes of
customer migrations
let's get to the really exciting section
what you are waiting for so without
further ado we're making the following
announcements today
we are increasing
our translation
to be enhanced with large language
models so we are announcing large
language models enhanced translations
today I have a short demo
uh we're also announcing enhanced UI for
when you run translation when you run
assessment whatever are the next step
actions for you they are getting more
prescriptive
so that's one bucket the second is on
the assessment piece itself we are
announcing availability of assessment
for two more sources
Snowflake and hive
and we're also announcing
in the assessment the ability for
a customer or for a partner to run the
assessment and determine what would
their cost of ownership in bigquery over
a three year five year two year one year
Horizon look like
so that's pretty powerful just looking
at your workload no human involvement no
fill in questionnaires and we give you a
ballpark
on the translation core piece we are
continuously adding capabilities
so we're announcing
availability for teradata Advantage SQL
to bigquery conversion and TPT to
bigquery
we are announcing support for Hive ql b
line CLI within our generally available
Hive translation capability
and we are announcing support for IBM
db2 to bigquery
so let's talk a little bit about llm
enhanced translations I think this is
being a really uh interesting area so
what we are doing is we're doing an
experimental launch not today but four
to five weeks from now and a demo will
represent what that launch will include
so what we are doing is think of it like
this today when you submit a translation
job
our compiler Our Best in Class compiler
does the translation now you'll have the
ability to annotate if you want an llm
to enhance your translation
if you do that and llm would be able to
do a few things
it would be able to suggest
different possibilities of outputs in
case there is an ambiguity in
Translation and you as the user get to
decide what is the right context for a
translation
so if you're converting for example from
teradata to bigquery you will have
wherever there are ambiguities you will
have options to choose from that's
number one
number two if you have a customized
environment
which most of the complex environments
do and this is a very complex space
then you will have the ability to Define
patterns or semantics which then the
element will automatically apply to
similar patterns in your code throughout
not just that
when it actually
gets out the translation output it will
give you an option
keep it or do away with it meaning you
will clearly see llm annotated text l m
translated text annotated by hey this is
l m enhanced do you want to keep it or
not
and the reason for doing that is we know
llms hallucinate we know llms give an
output where you know it may not be
correct or at least not be correct in
your business context so we want you to
be able to make that determination
but then we go a step further
what we do is when we do present the llm
enhanced output in the background we
will check that for you so to overcome
the hallucination problem we would have
verified that what the llm output
indeed is runable in bigquery that's a
minimum that's a starting position
and finally when all of this is done you
have the option to either apply all of
the llm suggestions or select pick and
select from them
and we do not use llm output or data
for our model training purposes that's
your data these run in your projects
this data is stored in your buckets
we don't have access to that so that's
very important to know
so let's jump into the demo
and see what we're talking about
welcome to the arm enhanced SQL
translation demo the first the demo is
AI suggestion well the translation shows
a narrow
in the bigquery SQL editor click the
enable SQL translation button to enter
the SQL translation UI
it translates a dozen of SQL dialects
into Google SQL
here's a creatable ddl with default
column constraints click the translate
button and enable AI enhanced SQL
translation
and then we get the output on the right
is the original translation engine
output with arrows
the arrow is about the default column
constraints are not yet supported
in the AI suggestion we provide the lrm
generated result after fixing this Arrow
we had this validation button to perform
syntax validation and another action
button to apply AI suggestion click the
button
and then the original translation output
is replaced by this AI suggestion and
the default colon constraints are added
into the translated query
the second demo is customize the SQL
translation with human input and output
an input query it joins two tables on
the ZIP code column one simple column is
water and the other one is integer
column
the results returned by compiler is
correct but it introduces extra logic to
cover the corner cases when string count
basically cast as integer
but for this case the user knows the
Deep code colon should be integer so
they want to simplify the output
to achieve this the user could provide
generic input and output guidance
and let's translate this SQL again
the RM simplifies the result by casting
string into integer following the
example provided by the user
that's all for the demo thanks for
watching
quick table
so that's an element enhanced
translations
now let's just roll back what we talked
in the last five ten minutes 15 minutes
with today's announcements from the
product side
this is what bigquery migration Services
looks like the greens highlight the
announcements we've made today that we
just covered
and one thing to call out is that we
have seen tremendous scale in the use of
the service
as you saw on a previous slide
we have customers translating millions
of SQL lines millions of lines of SQL
code and we have customers
migrating
petabytes
of data and the service automation
enables that so if you have questions
specifics on what we can do and what you
know would be best done with a partner
or you know even for your business cases
like for your organization's cases what
are some of the peculiarities what are
some of the business risks you're
concerned about please reach out to us
always always happy to talk to you
some
forward-looking announcements what's
upcoming
so what we will do between now and the
next few months is
we're adding deep assessments for
additional sources so we have them for
four now in today's announcement
teradata redshift snowflake And Hive
we're going to add more sources and
we're going to deepen the coverage for
these assessments
what we are also doing is we are
launching an API for individual strings
so what you can do is you can call that
API and pass it a string that string can
be a query multiple queries it'll just
do a query by query translation law for
partners have asked for this capability
simply because they want to integrate
this translation into their tooling so
this is what we're doing for that
we will keep improving our ux
we have made substantial improvements
but we are not done there's more coming
we are adding more sources more formats
for translation customization so
specifying rules we have a pretty rich
way for you to be able to specify macro
substitution and a whole bunch of things
but we'll keep adding we'll keep making
improvements to that
one thing is
has this translation proceeds
at every step we'll be trying to
optimize your state
for when you land on bigquery which
means that performance optimization
based on your Source context based on
what you specified will happen in the
background so that when you do land on
bigquery
we are ready to hand you over to the
bigquery optimization engine which means
that we would have optimized you to the
extent possible based on your Source
context and make you as ready as
possible to run your queries effectively
on bigquery query performance so that's
that's a big Focus
we'd also be building out a first class
lineage product
which is column 11 lineage Source
lineage so for teradata for Oracle for
any Source systems and it will analyze
the impact of dependencies and enhance
our ability
to automatically recommend them
recommend a migration plan show all the
different dependencies and help you be
able to structure and segment the
migration more deterministically
and finally we'll be adding more sources
and more capabilities for improving data
gravity for improving data migration
of announcements pertain to Google Cloud
Consulting and they have a booth right
around please go and talk to them if you
have more questions about this
we heard our customers and our partners
that are Google Cloud Consulting
programs were a little bit rigid so what
we've done is we've made them very
modular
now you'll have the ability to engage
Google Cloud Consulting as just as a
trusted help source so if you have like
one-off questions you can do that if you
want to engage them deeper for a part of
your migration starting all the way from
proof of concept you can just engage
them for that specifically
if you are wanting to engage our Cloud
Consulting for bigger pieces of
migration you can do that and now as
always they're happy to work with you to
do the whole end-to-end migration if you
choose to do so
so what this is doing is two things one
is making the cloud Consulting model
more modular
and cheaper if you are looking for help
for certain areas the second piece it's
doing is it's making it easier for our
partners and our Cloud consultant to
work together more flexibility so these
are a few announcements please make sure
you talk to our Cloud Consulting folks
down the hall
and then the third part of announcements
and this is where it's really exciting
for a partner ecosystem
is we are announcing rapid proof of
value with partners
but now a partner can do is work with us
Google and if for example you're working
with a customer
and you want our help both in terms of
Technology as well as in terms of
covering some of the costs
we can help you with that so if you're
part of our trusted partner our core
partner program
we'll work with you for assessments
we'll also have a very modular offering
which is a rapid POV two to four weeks
and as it says it'll do a T-shirt size
proof of value it'll take one to three
use cases and prove the value so look at
the Timeline it's two to four weeks so
we are accelerating times and we're
lowering costs and lowering friction and
third piece is uh there's modernization
Factory so if you're a partner and
you're working with a customer or if
you're a customer and you also want to
approach us we'll help you pair up with
a partner
and what we'll do there in the
modernization factory is we do the
comprehensive
first-hand view of what
your migration uh proposal what your
migration architectures
what nuances will need to be covered as
part of the migration so again
what this is doing is rather than
Partners going for one-offs and partners
you know going and talking to customers
about the entire migration we have
bite-sized it
so now you can choose a small component
or you can choose a larger component
some select partners that we already
work with and hopefully you'll see a lot
of these names probably all of them down
in the hallway there are other partners
who are not listed on the slide and if
you're a partner who are interested in
working with us again either to benefit
from our technology or you want to work
with joint business programs with us
please reach out to us
here is where you can learn more and
with that
let me welcome JB for his story about
Seattle Children's migration
foreign
I am a director of data engineering
analytics whatever you can call titles
not that important nowadays
um
I am here to just give you a quick
overview of who we are what is our what
was our journey what we did and what
were our milestones and did we achieve
our Milestones it won't be too technical
you will see some technical slides you
can reach out to us and let I need the
clicker okay you can reach out to us at
any point in time and we can give you
more in-depth uh overview of what we did
and wrong direction
so ah so I'm from Seattle Children's I
am representing Hospital
analytics team which is run by Susan
Spencer
this is a quick overview of what
hospital children does today we provide
hope care and cure to help every child
live healthiest and most fulfilled
fulfilling life possible we have about
46 locations we are
about 9 000 plus employees we have 900
uh 1900 medical staff our gross revenue
as of 2022 was 3.3 billion
um our annual patient visit is about
400k uh outpatient is uh 250k and
impatient is about
15K and emergency room is 854k and
outpatient surgery is 11k and we have
407 licensed beds
for Hospital analytics team this is our
mission and vision we our mission is to
power data Innovation that drives
Equitable action to improve the lives of
children and their families
that's our vision over three over next
three years we want to expand and
Leverage The analytics AI platform to
power scientific discoveries real-time
assessment awareness and predictions and
seamless operational Integra integration
what it really does is we need to move
forward from where we were we were in
our rdbms system at this point in time
we want to empower
um our analytical Journey further
uh for our patient families employees
and broader community
so that's that's our journey before so
what are we are seeing on your far right
far left
um we before 2015 when we started our
journey we had our own data warehouse
which which was very limited and which
had very small Footprints there were a
lot of mini data warehouses across the
organization
um and our uptime was about 65 percent
um and and if we did hem stage
amm assessment we would be in stage one
or two right and then we were industry
followers not leaders
starting 20 2016 we Acquired natiza and
between 2016 and 2017 we acquired
Cloudera as well and we had now two
systems in which we put we we combined
all our data warehouse
um data we we have about 71 different
data sources that we bring data we even
bring real-time data from bed sites as
well in in Cloud era so the we had few
pros and then we have few cons as well
Pros were that now we had a unified
system with Hospital research and
Foundation we had a single trust single
source of trusted data
um and then now we have we started doing
cell service advanced analytics
automation all that was undergoing and
then we did a hymn 7 certification and
we got the higher certification at State
seven in 2019 end of 2019 but there were
some more things that we were not able
to do
um just to remind we are a hospital
industry and we we really need to focus
on giving care and to the patient and
empowering analytics and and scientific
discoveries right so we wanted to get
out of this day-to-day management of our
systems taking care of our hard drives
um we needed to even we did not have
proper integration with our data science
tools and our RTO and RPO was super low
with our netizer system IBM nutrition
system
um
after that uh we are hoping we just
finished our migration in August we are
hoping that future will be
everything that we had before will
remain a single source of Truth now
instead of having two different systems
um Cloudera and netiza we are going to
deprecate both we have deprecated netiza
we have stopped Refresh on that we will
be deprecating Cloudera as well at some
point in time next year and we will
bring all that data in bigquery and we
have one place to to run our reports to
have uh
to help our data scientists and
but this is where and plus will have
added benefits of AI and ml capabilities
as well
this these are our Milestones uh early
2001 we uh IBM came to us and let us
know that netiza will no longer be
available uh starting 2023 April and
there is no monetizer system
um after that uh obviously they did
bring in new netizer systems later on
but we've been unaware of it at that
point in time uh April 2021 we decided
that we'll start working on uh
um finding a newer system
um the next-gen system by August uh fall
and August we we had a 20 people team
that that represented all roles and
organizations across Seattle Children's
Hospital
these 20 people team decided this group
was formed to decide which next system
we are going to migrate to uh September
2021 we did a lot of vendor demos we had
David Jones as our TPM
in March we narrowed down to three
finalists and we did a lot of Deep dive
sessions and we created a scorecard uh
and then we find uh finally decided to
go with Google right May 2022 onwards we
did pricing negotiation
um vendor engagement
um and then August 2022 we had a final
recommendation by November 2022 we had
funding approved and December we started
our training sessions
mind you we are none of our employees
were
um Savvy with any Cloud infrastructure
as such this is our first journey and we
started just training in December 2022
Google was with us training us
constantly
um and we had a lot of one-off seminars
we had the Google Cloud hero session so
that people can at least join us get
certified
and then in January 2023 we started our
ETL migration
um by mid-may we finished our ATL
migration I will show you the scale at
which what we did how much we migrated
in the next slide but it wasn't easy it
was super hard but but we had support we
had support tremendous support from
Google and partners
um mid-may we finished ETL migration and
by all April uh and August we finished
our data validation report migration and
everything
we just shut down it is a refresh
actually on 18th of this month
so we are that Fresh So if you see me
sweating here and that's why
uh what did we migrate we migrated over
650 databases from netiza 57 000
database objects in those four and a
half months 1.7 million lines of code 30
000 scripts three homegrown automated
tools were migrated because all our
automated tools were catered towards
data stage in the teaser
13 self-service models on 1000 plus
reports many reports we decided we won't
even migrate so that is a plus of doing
a complete migration to a new system and
then we might we even decommissioned 580
plus reports as well
we have 200 plus file extracts that goes
to internal and external Partners we
migrated those and we also migrated to
SQL Server cubes
you can see on your right
um what was our architecture before it
is super super high level there's so
many
components I have not mentioned here but
one thing to note there is we have 71
different data sources epic and Cerner
these big systems are like one or two of
them so we have more much more
data sources even our operational data
like jira service now everything goes
into our data warehouse
so these are all these were our main
objectives right
um and did and I will go through one by
one and let you know did we achieve them
or not uh we build we wanted to build a
data warehouse that was sustainable that
we can grow we did not want to do
migration every five years
negotiating every five years and then
not only you have to negotiate with
with your vendor Partners but we have to
also negotiate with our data center team
acquire a space and all so we did not
want to do that going forward
um and we also needed capabilities where
we can do our AIML NLP and image
analytics
um we want we so we achieved that we did
a Brownfield migration so minimal change
attained parity whatever possible just
don't
um don't change any business logic and
and not increase our cost as well so so
that's that we achieved have a partner
and we we wanted to have a partner to
migrate our current ETL workflow we had
a partner with Google and
this is where Google helped us the most
they held our partners accountable to
finish the migration and finish the
Finish every component of the migration
so thanks to Google team
um
and have we we wanted tools um Google
had tools like
um
bigquery migration service I mean teams
like bigquery migrant services and
Professional Services these teams were
available whenever we wanted them they
were available designed the architecture
with us help us to help us to teach what
each one of these component means when
to use it where to use it how to use it
so I'm super super thankful to Google
and PSO team as well
um
and then we as I said we had to train
our employees we have 90 plus people in
in our team alone and we had to train
all our analysts we have to train all
our Engineers we had to train our data
scientists how to use bigquery
um and how to even use bigquery console
and navigate it
um and then we had
um as I said we finished our uh we we
were supposed to finish our Migration by
end of April we couldn't we had to
extend it a bit by 15-20 Days by then we
our nitisha support was over but we were
able to migrate successfully we wanted
to increase our SLA from 99 of time to
99.99 again to keep that 99 uptime on it
is it was super hard because every time
we have to do any upgrades or
enhancements we had to flip to our Dr
system and all that flipping back and
forth was manual
um
have we we wanted to have a better RPO
and RTO uh with with our netizer system
we can only go back about 24 hours here
we can be real time and because Google
has a capability that you can turn back
seven days that was super super helpful
for us to keep our slas
um bring better visibility to our
operational expense
so with when you when you go and buy a
system like uh data center system you
have to spend your capex and you're
spending like five million six million
dollars uh the scale at me which we are
buying right
at this time frame we did not have to
spend all that at once
um
if I may right now as we are going
progressing I think we would be spending
less than what we would have spent with
with our data center
um acquisition so at least let me give
you that much
um feedback from cost perspective
um
we wanted to increase our ability to
innovate in future we wanted to make
sure that all our tools are working
right Google bigquery does connect to
Tableau power bi are jupyter notebook
and and obviously it also supports
native python as well
um we wanted to build a self-healing
rollback ETL process so we we do have we
have seen our ETL processes fail at
night we have to get up at night today
even right after our migration
we have already built self-healing ETL
processes whenever our data proc systems
they have any issues
we can destroy them rebuild them
automatically we don't really have to
get up our systems have been we have
started automating that process already
um and as I said we just finished our
migration on 18th so think about it how
quickly we are trying we are able to
automate these processes
um and then we wanted to use the
resources when and when it is required
so all of our data procs servers right
now we are using so data box servers we
wanted to migrate to serverless at some
point in time but just to keep parity we
are using data box servers but we only
spin them up when our etls are running
as soon as our retails are done we
destroy them and we don't incur any more
cost at all give just to give you uh a
data point from SLA perspective we were
meeting our slas by 8 am in the morning
because of what we have done so far that
em ATM SLA we are meeting now by 4 30 in
the morning
as well so tremendous tremendous
performance uh benefit as well
and and then obviously um one of our
main criteria was that our our next
system should be completely HIPAA
certified which is Google is completely
HIPAA certified as well with all the
components that we have used here
and this is our new very high level
architecture that we moved to thank you
for your time
[Music]
foreign